on this wednesday night the misery over
money canada's inflation rate skyrockets
to a 39-year high everything is more
expensive how rising costs are eroding
peace of mind a powerful earthquake
pummels a part of afghanistan it's in a
country that's already on the drink the
staggering death toll and devastation
damning claims and denials the
allegations of interference in the nova
scotia massacre investigation and hot
shot it speaks volume of his character
and his resilience and his perseverance
a montreal teen's journey to the nba
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
inflation anxiety is accelerating across
canada tonight consumer demand is
driving up the price of just about
everything the latest data shows
inflation has now climbed to a level not
seen in nearly 40 years reaching 7.7
percent in may the largest spike since
1983.
a major factor is the price of gas up a
whopping 48 percent compared to a year
ago with everyone's budgets being
squeezed experts say it's time to
eliminate unnecessary spending and there
are growing fears the rampaging
inflation could tip the economy into a
recession so how do canadian families
navigate the rising costs tonight ann
gaviola takes a deep dive into that and
why consumers will continue to feel the
financial pinch
the rising cost of living has gone from
being a fact of life or mild annoyance
to the main source of financial anxiety
and there's no escaping it housing
prices are out of control car prices are
to control grocery prices are ticking
higher 85 percent of respondents to a
new ipsos poll done exclusively for
global news are stressed their income
won't keep up with inflation
women who as a group earn less than
their male counterparts are more likely
to worry their wages won't keep pace
with the rising cost of everything
unsurprisingly low-income households
making less than forty thousand annually
are feeling the most stress with more
than 90 percent worried
significantly more than the 8 in 10
households making between 60 and 100k
93 percent of those in their prime
working years fret about it more than
the 82 percent of workers aged 18 to 34.
there's a generational divide where
their parents or grandparents might be
looking at this and they're fine because
they they have had the increase in their
housing prices over the number last
number of years
happen and and they're less worried
about it with food inflation one of the
biggest contributors to overall
inflation it's no surprise households
with more mouths to feed are most
concerned 72 percent of families with
kids are stressed about inflation
compared with 57 percent of households
without children and none of this
happens in a vacuum the stock market is
selling off and volatile and more than
70 percent believe interest rates will
rise quicker than they'll be able to
adjust
leaving many families to make hard
choices on where to cut back there are
other things that you should be saving
for like retirement your kids education
paying down your own student bill
student loans for example and those
things tend to go by the wayside when
everything snowballs into just being
more expensive overall for some
households tough financial choices mean
a staycation instead of a vacation
abroad others will choose which bills
get paid and which ones don't ann
gaviola global news toronto
in the u.s president joe biden is hoping
to ease the financial pressure on
americans by suspending the federal gas
tax biden is calling on congress to put
a three-month pause on federal gas and
diesel taxes he's also asking states to
suspend their own gas taxes or provide
similar relief and biden is urging
energy companies to increase refining
capacity the measures are aimed at
bringing down the country's soaring
energy prices but are expected to face
opposition in congress
to afghanistan now where a powerful
earthquake has caused widespread death
and destruction in the country's east
killing one thousand people a toll that
will likely rise as crews combed the
rubble in remote areas the disaster
compounds a hunger crisis and economic
collapse that followed the frantic
withdrawal of u.s led troops last year
redmond shannon has more
the desperate search for survivors in
the hours after a magnitude 6 earthquake
most of the death and devastation is in
the remote eastern pacika province along
the pakistan border
the injured carried to helicopters in
blankets there's no sophisticated
equipment up in these villages
these are people who lived hand-to-mouth
many of the dead reportedly children
asleep when the earthquake hit these are
very simple homes made of mud bricks
that crumble really really easily and so
we're deeply concerned that there are
still people underneath
the rubble that haven't been rescued yet
it was so dangerous we left home
immediately says this man a lot of
people were injured it is the deadliest
earthquake in afghanistan in at least
two decades felt as far away as india
the devastation compounding an ongoing
drought a hunger crisis and the economic
collapse following the departure of u.s
led troops last year
since the taliban took over the west has
withdrawn state aid in protest against
the regime's human rights policies
including its ban on girls attending
high school
all the development agencies or most of
them left afghanistan
so what it means concretely for the
population is is additional challenges
to face on daily basis it's left a
desperately poor country even less able
to deal with a disaster like this
countries like canada only send
humanitarian aid via organizations like
the un what i've said to all my
counterparts in the house of commons is
i'm willing to work with them to find a
solution meanwhile there is a hard work
that just happened we need to make sure
that
aid is sent and we'll work with the u.n
before any extra international aid
arrives it is feared the death toll will
rise redmond shannon global news london
more than a dozen conservative mps
welcomed key figures of the so-called
freedom movement to parliament hill the
visitors included james top who recently
walked from bc to ottawa to protest
vaccine mandates and tom morazzo a key
spokesperson for the convoy protests in
ottawa earlier this year they were
greeted by several conservative mps
including leadership candidate leslie
lewis and saskatchewan mp jeremy patzer
the reality is there's one political
party that has been represented around
this table here today
there's one political party that has
stood up in the house of commons from
before the last election last federal
election and stood up and spoke on the
position that you guys are here
with today you do have allies you've had
allies all along
panzer's comments came moments after
marazzo suggested canada is on what he
called a dark path showing similarities
to countries about to descend into quote
civil war a spokesperson for opposition
leader candice bergen's office said they
were aware of the event but had no hand
in setting it up the organizers said
their intentions for future
demonstrations are peaceful as ottawa
braces for another protest scheduled for
canada day
the liberal government and head of the
rcmp are denying there was any political
interference in the investigation of
canada's worst mass shooting the 2020
killings in port-a-pick nova scotia the
opposition and even the liberals allies
the ndp are now calling for a larger
investigation into claims rcmp
commissioner brenda lucky pushed for
more information to be released to help
the government further their gun control
agenda ross lord reports
they are damning allegations it's
sickening to think that they're using
the worst mass shooting in canadian
history for political gain but it is
very possible allegations the government
denies
at no point mr speaker did our
government pressure or interfere in the
operational decisions of the rcmp
at the center of the controversy the
porter pick gunman's weapons most
unregistered and smuggled into nova
scotia from the united states the public
inquiry investigating the massacre
revealed handwritten notes from rcmp
superintendent darren campbell that
indicate commissioner brenda lucky
pressured nova scotia maoris to reveal
more details about the weapons at public
briefings she conveyed that she had
that they had disobeyed her instructions
to include specific information on the
firearms used by the perpetrator and
that she had promised minister blair and
the prime minister's office that they
would release information
that was tied to pending gun control
legislate legislation in a written
statement commissioner lucky insists i
did not interfere in the ongoing
investigations into the largest mass
shooting in canadian history she says
she should have been more sensitive in
her approach to the meeting in question
and that i regret the way i approached
the meeting and the impact it had on
those in attendance
bill blair who was public safety
minister at the time of the massacre
insists there was nothing nefarious
there was no pressure placed upon the
rcmp no interference with their
operational decisions this is this is
actually an important line between
government and and the operations of of
the police commissioner and the rcmp
it's a line that has always been
respected
not exactly in 1997 the office of
liberal prime minister jean cretcham was
blamed for interfering with police
operations that included rcmp pepper
spring protesters at an economic summit
in vancouver the current allegations are
not going away even the ndp which has
formally agreed to support the liberal
government for the next three years is
calling for an emergency meeting of the
commons public safety committee
ross lord global news
south of the border the school where 19
children and two teachers were gunned
down last month will be demolished the
mayor of uvalde texas made the
announcement last night but did not give
a timeline for when robb elementary
school will be torn down
for the first time in decades major
legislation on gun control in the u.s
could be put to a vote this week the
senate has reached a bipartisan deal on
a gun violence bill it includes measures
to tighten background checks bolster
spending for school safety and tougher
penalties for gun traffickers
allegations of torture coming up
ukrainian prisoners of war with
disturbing claims against russian forces
the u.n estimates more than 4 600
civilians have been killed since russia
invaded ukraine in late february but
that number doesn't include the
staggering toll on ukrainian soldiers
and those taken as prisoners of war
human rights watchers say ukrainians in
detention could number six thousand and
those lucky enough to be released are
now speaking out about their experiences
sean o'shea spoke to one of them
you were beaten for pleasure
yes
he asked us not to show his face agreed
to speak to us if we didn't use his name
then he emotionally described what he
and others went through at the hands of
russian soldiers they did elect they use
electroshock
mixture
on
genitals
he signed up just after the invasion his
military unit was surrounded by the
enemy and they surrendered he spent
three weeks as a prisoner of war the
torture techniques they used he told us
weren't just painful
during 10 minutes of physical torture he
said a man with us died human rights
watchers say they've heard accounts from
soldiers and civilians alike every
person
who was interviewed by our ngo told us
about the tortured
in the russian captivity
[Music]
in ukrainian areas now controlled by
russians ordinary
men who were
walking across the street and abducted
by russians vladimir zulkin is a blogger
and journalist who says he's seen videos
of captured ukrainians who've been
tortured
as for russians captured by ukraine he's
managed to interview those soldiers on
video and even contacted the soldiers
families it's stupid he says families
and soldiers have been brainwashed by
russian propaganda he says he feels pity
for some of the russian soldiers who
were tricked to join the fighting what
would you like canadians to know about
the way the russians are treating the
ukrainians the civilians in this war
russians want one want to destroy all
our lives so they want to kill everyone
if if they can they kill every ukrainian
i want canadians to know that we
will resist
and we will fight until
the
our wind
until we defeat this evil this man got
out in a prisoner swap his legs injured
by an exploded grenade are slowly
healing and over lunch at his home that
prisoner of war told us something else
that despite the conditions he faced in
captivity once his injuries are better
he says he wants to return to the front
lines to continue defending his country
which is still under attack
nithu
shawn o'shea in harkeev ukraine thanks
sean
back in canada ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky holding a virtual q a
with university students from across the
country students say the opportunity to
hear from the wartime leader was
inspiring and while zolensky expressed
gratitude for their support he also
stressed his country's need for more
help heather urex west reports
ilya yankue is studying at the
university of calgary but his heart is
back in ukraine for me
specifically it was really
hard because
my father is in ukraine armed forces and
he was especially
he was directly on the front line yankue
looks towards a day he can return armed
with his education back home when you
look
at your children speaking live to an
audience of a dozen canadian
universities wednesday the ukraine
president said the country will need
people like him soon do come back
with the state of art knowledge and with
the willingness to live
and build independent ukraine
and we are standing here for this i'm
sure speaking via video link zelinski
lamented how much things had changed
since his visit to toronto in 2019. the
year he said the toronto raptors
surprised everyone with a championship
victory just as ukraine is surprising
much of the world now this is when you
win
when no one is expecting you to win
by bringing together and uniting you do
things that seem to be impossible
canada's deputy prime minister christia
freeland also watched the president's
address with students at the university
of toronto we heard president zielinski
say that what ukraine needs is money it
needs weapons
and it needs ever stronger sanctions
against russia
we agree and my question is after
speaking the president took questions
from canadian students ukraine exchange
student katarina nekoumiaj says hearing
directly from zelinski meant a lot i
felt really proud
proud for our people for our president i
felt really grateful to everyone who
helps ukraine and supports it thank you
very much a rare opportunity to speak
with a wartime president these students
aren't likely to forget
heather urex west global news calgary
[Applause]
still ahead what's on trudeau's agenda
for the commonwealth summit in rwanda
you're watching global national
[Music]
the federal government is freezing
funding for hockey canada over its
handling of sexual assault allegations
the decision to cut the funding comes
just two days after hockey canada
executives testified on parliament hill
about the organization's handling of a
sexual assault complaint involving
members of the 2018 world junior men's
team in the last two years hockey canada
received 14 million dollars from the
federal government
the trudeau government says canada will
open an embassy in the rwandan capital
of kigali the first stop in a trio of
international summits for the prime
minister his government says it hopes to
strengthen diplomatic relations in the
region our chief political correspondent
david aiken is traveling with the prime
minister david what can we expect on
this international trip
well this is the first of three summits
the prime minister will engage in over
the next 10 days with all the crises in
the world they are all important
here in kigali justin trudeau will have
face-to-face meetings with many of the
commonwealth leaders who have yet to
denounce russia's invasion of ukraine uh
the prime minister's officials telling
us that the prime minister will have
some quote frank conversations to
connect the dots between russia's
invasion food shortages supply chain
issues and inflation
well i think that's why it's important
to be here
to hear their perspective to engage it
may be tough to find consensus india for
example has yet to condemn russia's
invasion of ukraine and in fact india's
prime minister narendra modi he is not
at this summit officials in fact worry
that there may not even be a mention of
ukraine in the summit's final communique
now there's 54 members of the
commonwealth but 32 are small island
states in the pacific and caribbean
their top issue climate change it is
literally an existential issue for many
of these states some of which could
literally be underwater within decades
they are looking for wealthy countries
like canada like the uk to help with
financing they need to adapt to rising
sea levels and deal with ever more
destructive hurricanes and typhoons
finally justin trudeau and other leaders
have been put on notice by some activist
groups like amnesty international to
confront the human rights record of
their host rwanda prime minister paul
kagame kagame's government has been
accused of illegally jailing its critics
torturing some critics and even engaging
in some extrajudicial killings now
officials from the pmo say that trudeau
will not hesitate to bring these matters
up when trudeau and kagami meet later
this week nitu david aiken in rwanda
thanks david
next the high flying hopes for a
montreal teen trailblazer at the nba
draft
the nba draft is tomorrow night and one
of the most highly touted prospects is a
canadian nineteen-year-old benedict
matheran from montreal seems destined
for stardom with his smooth shots and
thunderous dunks he's the latest in what
some are calling the golden age of
canadian basketball dan spector has more
on matheran's talent with the ball and
how he's shown strength off the court
he may not be a household name yet but a
whole lot more canadians are about to
get acquainted with 19 year old benedict
matsuring better known south of the
border as ben matherin the montreal
native regularly made crowds go wild
while starring for the university of
arizona for the past two seasons
thursday night matheran is a lock to be
picked high in the nba draft
top six
at the very least
former canadian national team member
dwight walton says matheran will make an
instant impact in the nba his metrics
are off the chart
he is nba
ready now but long before he was
electrifying packed stadiums in college
matheran played on this court in
montreal north one of the city's poorest
neighborhoods he followed his older
sister jennifer an elite basketball
player in her own right i'm just really
proud the game helped jen and ben cope
with the loss of their brother who died
at 15 in a bicycle accident just under a
decade ago matheran choosing to work
even harder to honor his fallen sibling
i think it speaks volume of his
character and his resilience and his
perseverance now ben is set to make the
ultimate leap as more and more canadians
have been doing in recent years
without question it's a golden age
ontario-born nba stars like andrew
wiggins and jamal murray are among those
cementing canada's reputation as a
basketball powerhouse but quebec has
been catching up with chris boucher
logan stort and now matheran all coming
out of montreal north i think that's
going to just catapult basketball more
and give kids more of a chance matheran
says he hopes his story convinces other
kids to believe in themselves even when
nobody else does dan specter global news
montreal
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm nitu garcia
tonight's your canada is this rainbow
over toronto we love to see your
candidate please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching bar nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
you